hands up guys my name is the chana
welcome back to another one of these
hazel development locks today I'm going
to be talking about what has happened in
the last two weeks with hazel as most of
you probably know the way that I like to
create these videos is to divide them
into two parts really there's this kind
of beginning part of me talking to the
camera and this is a lot more focused on
my life in the last two weeks rather
than hazel specifically although I do
tend to talk about programming and game
engine development related topics as
well and then there's the second half of
the video that is just me showing what's
new in hazel dev now if I do say so
myself I think that the best way to
enjoy these videos is to watch the whole
video but for those of you who are only
interested in either this part or the
hazel dev part I've added timestamps in
the description of this video and they
should show up in the actual video like
timeline so if you if you want to jump
to the hazel dev part then you can do
that because I care about you for those
of you who live in Australia I think you
probably know that the situation with
the virus is mmm more or less getting a
little bit out of hand particularly in
Victoria which is the state that I live
in and because of that we've basically
gone on to lockdown again
so because of that I think that I have
been feeling kind of a little bit down
lately probably haven't done as much
work as I wanted to just because of the
fact that like it did you know it brings
you down I'm really grateful that my
family and I were able to go out on a
little three-day holiday to the
mountains and see some snow here in
Australia this winter snow season before
the lockdowns actually commenced so
super happy that I got that little
holiday and because if I didn't well
anyway that little holiday meant that I
have less time during these two weeks to
work on hazel which I'm totally happy
with the biggest thing that I've been
focusing on for hazel as most of you
know has been the whole 2d workflow
thing so I want to be able to create a
game from scratch using just hazel all
of that workflow should be present in
the editor in the actual engine runtime
everywhere and a big part of creating
games is actually filling them with some
sort of content just having a scripting
language is fine and there's a lot that
you can accomplish with that but
ultimately the way that you add content
to a game using you know
an engine such as unity or unreal is
typically by just adding components to
entities so if there are various
different component types they have
certain behaviors or some kind of work
attached to them and by adding new
component types that's essentially how
you add content to a game engine the
thing is once you have an HD component
system and a scene system and all of
that is kind of running as it is now
with hazel every little thing that the
engine is going to support could
theoretically be added as a component to
an entity now whether or not you want to
absolutely add everything that your
engine actually supports as a component
is debatable I probably wouldn't do that
some things should be intrinsic to the
actual core of the engine itself and
probably should not be present as
components in the entity component
system but again that's that's the topic
that's that's a big topic so because of
that I do want to actually add
everything I need to be able to make a
game using hazel now I've done this
before I've made a game in about an hour
using hazel I'll have it linked up there
for those of you who have not seen it
basically like a little flappy bird
clone I made that entirely using code
because that's all that hazel had back
then I want to repeat that experiment
very soon maybe in the next couple
months or so I want to repeat that
experiment make the exact same game
again however now using hazel dev and
all of the features that are built in
once I deem it ready enough so in other
words I want to make that game from
scratch using hazel darish probably be
able to make the whole thing in an hour
instead of like making the base game in
an hour and then spending another hour
hacking in various effects and particle
systems and stuff like that I think
it'll be a really cool way to see how
far hazel has actually come now in that
video idea to use the public version of
hazel words for this I probably use the
development version of hazel however I
think that it's still going to be a
really good test and so because of that
I've basically been using that style of
game as a little bit of a guide to
determine what features I want to add
and in what order because ultimately
speaking you know a game engine is very
open-ended there are like a list of
probably like a huge list of core
components that you want to have
regardless of
what you're trying to make and and
things that I guess users of game
engines would expect to be present in a
new engine that they pick up and start
using however instead of just going
through that list and everything being
really boring I've kind of had this game
in mind as my goal and that's why it's
really important I think to to set goals
that aren't simply lists of of work that
you have to do but rather a concrete
kind of goal that results in an end
product that you are able to create in
an in like a fairly manageable like a
small amount of time not something is
gonna take you a year but something that
maybe you can accomplish in the next few
months and that way you can actually
well in my case build that game and then
you'll have that game that you built
using your technology you had to add
everything along the way to make that
happen
and there you go it's possible now and I
think that that's a there's a really
good way of working at it so with that
goal in mind I had to look at that game
and I had to think about what things are
required for hazel to make that happen
now the first most obvious thing about
from like the sprite rendering which
already exists to to some degree anyway
is the physics so that's a 2-d game
there needs to be some kind of 2d
physics system not just for actual rigid
body physics and like things bouncing
around and hitting each other and stuff
like that but actually just plain old
collision detection as well so being
able to see if this square intersects
this other square or if this triangle
intersects this polygon or something
like that that kind of collision system
is something that one of the first
things that I think of when I think of
what's required to build a 2-d game
because even if you don't have actual
like you know a bouncy physics of things
bouncing against walls and more or less
realistic in in a more or less realistic
way you still need to be able to detect
hey is my character walking through a
wall and or not and because of that we
need to have some kind of physics system
so that's what I decided to do over the
last few weeks I added box 2d as a
physics system into hazel so now we
basically I mean I cooked it and did my
usual thing of adding a pre-made file to
it and then adding that into hazel dev
hazel dev now has that and I've added a
few better two components two very
simple components a rigidbody 2d and
box Collider component box Collider 2d
component probably don't remember what
it's called but basically those two
components together how you can add
physics to basically anything and what
happens is physics is entirely a runtime
system so you can set up your physics
and your rigid bodies and all that stuff
obviously while you're in the editor but
before you hit play nothing's gonna be
simulated now I know that some engines
have like a simulate button and that is
quite useful I think so in other words
that will just more or less play your
scene but leave you in the editor views
that's good for like you know checking
hey is this material bouncy enough when
you're working with physics materials
stuff that we don't really have yet but
ultimately for now I've just said no I'm
not going to do that that's gonna be too
too much work to implement everything
now let's start with the basics and so
what I've got is when you hit play the
physics will play because at that point
they will actually be added to a box 2d
world and simulated properly so that's
what happens and then of course there
are certain like parameters with the
world itself that you want to set up
such as like the gravity what that's set
to which I haven't really exposed into
I'm going controls yet but that's gonna
be part of the same so with that in mind
we have physics and that's what I'm
about to show you when we switch over to
looking at hazel dev itself but
ultimately ultimately with that system
in place the biggest thing I think is
remaining above from just fleshing it
out so again we just have box colliders
now we obviously want to be able to have
like circle colliders polygons various
polygons stuff like that triangles that
stuff is also very important because we
have more than just square shapes
usually but also the biggest thing that
I see at the moment is the whole
collision callback system so in other
words I want to know if an entity
collides with another entity and I want
to be able to handle that in my c-sharp
script speaking of c-sharp scripts one
of the things that I have exposed
actually is impulses so in other words
you can add like a force or an impulse
to a body using c-sharp and I'll show
you that in a minute as well so that's
pretty cool because apart from just
simulating like a world of physics I was
also able to make the WASD Keys actually
move the entity via impulses so that's
pretty cool
I think as well the last thing that I
wanted to
was 2d physics don't necessarily have to
be used with 2d rendering
there's nothing about 2d physics that
links it to 2d rendering you can rent
you can still use 3d rendering and
render everything as 3d but simulate
your physics in a 2d space there's
nothing to stop you from doing that and
that's what my demo does as well because
we do have 3d rendering in hazel so all
I do is I have added I mean I've got
some meshes above my 3d meshes and
entities with those mesh components I've
added a rigidbody component to it and
now it's obviously you know it's
obviously constrained to axis of
movement it's constrained to X and y you
can't move it in terms of like the z
axis or anything like that because box
2d of course only simulates two
dimensions of physics so you can't
really use it in that sense but you can
still move the camera three
dimensionally everything is still
rendering three dimensionally it's still
using physically based rendering so you
get all of the benefits that you can
have from that it's just that when
entities move they move into two
directions or two dimensions right so
that's another thing that's worth noting
just because I haven't added 3d physics
to hazal doesn't mean that you can't
make 3d games using those physics you
absolutely can and that's what I've done
in my demo anyway Before we jump into
hazel dev and see all this in action I
want to give a huge thank you to all of
my patreon supporters who make all this
hazel development possible if it wasn't
for you guys I would not be working on
the hazel more-or-less full time and I
wouldn't be making videos talking about
it and teaching like how to make game
engines and doing all this stuff so
thank you everyone for your support
patron Archon force Ashley Turner is the
best way to help support everything that
I'm doing here and if you do help
support everything that I'm doing here
you'll also get access to all of these
hazel development code as well as weekly
live streams where I work on this stuff
so if you're interested in seeing you
interested in trying this stuff out for
yourself as you see it in this video
today then definitely jump on board on
patreon and apart from getting access to
all this fun stuff you'll know that you
are making it possible for me to
actually develop and add new features to
all of this stuff so anyway let's dive
in and take a look ok so here we are in
hazel dev I've decided to be a little
bit more chill with the way that I
actually talk about this stuff rather
than trying to define some kind of like
script essentially
of what I'll be showing in this video up
front and then like making sure
everything works I'm just gonna go with
it because I think Hazel's getting to
the point where first of all I might
come up with stuff to talk about on the
fly but also I want to show you this
actual engine in action and not just
like some kind of code path that I know
is stable and work so in other words if
this crashes that I'm sorry but you'll
know that it's real all right so if I
want one small thing that I added there
are some changes that I'll go through
here but essentially the current scene
is now written up here as well as
hazelnut and also what what kind of
build we're running so otherwise this is
a Windows x64 build and where this is a
release build so if we go file open
scene I've made a scene here called
physics 2d test which is my kind of test
of the 2d physics that I've added this
is what it looks like here the other
thing that I've added is this kind of
script menu here which has reload
c-sharp assembly and also reload
assembly on play so if you click on this
it becomes checked what this now will do
is every time I hit play it's actually
going to reload the assembly here so I
have a few different kind of different
scripts that I've played with and we'll
see that in a minute but we basically
have this player cube script you can see
that if you look at this you'll see the
API and how everything works we have
this horizontal force and vertical force
floats being exposed we have the
rigidbody 2d component which were
acquiring in the oncreate function by
just doing this the mesh component this
was a way for us to just this was I was
playing around with different materials
and this is just a way to set the
metalness of the play cube specific
specifically to zero because I think
what I had at some point was this random
color script which basically will just
select a random color and yeah I mean
this API is a little bit clunky at the
moment we have to get material number
zero we have to set this string because
that's the name of the uniform that
we're using in GLSL to a certain value
obviously is very dodgy but this is
still kind of early days back in play a
cube though where everything fun happens
in the on update function you can see
that I'm able to apply a linear impulse
based on the horizontal force to an
offset of like zero so it'll occur at
them in the middle of the actual entity
in this case and false I think is four
or wake and that's just these are mostly
box2d kind of arguments here the a key
we'll move it left presumably and in the
space key unable to add vertical force
so we kind of it's almost like we're
simulating a jump not really I mean it's
just gonna move it up if we keep it
pressed this what is this code oh yeah
okay then this code by the way I wrote
about a week ago almost so that's why
I'm I'm kind of looking at it for the
first time in a while but I did say this
would be more chill so here you go the
color here is if you press the Q key it
just changes the color to be red and you
can see over here I think it just sets
it to whatever the color is so this is a
nice little way for us to and I can move
this up this is a nice little way for us
to just basically test to see if we can
press the Q key and change the color to
red this was initially going to be me
actually once I added the collision
callbacks all of the collision events
and if I handled him here I was just
gonna make the actual cube go red if it
hits something but I haven't done the
callbacks yet so at the moment and we
can just press the Q key to see that
happen but this is still just more or
less a test of the actual API so if we
go back to our editor you can see
there's a whole bunch of boxes here I
think I showed this last time but you
can also click on it and then if you
press control D it will actually make a
copy of it which you can then move
somewhere so that will duplicate the
entity so I've done that a lot and that
way I've created all these boxes it
wasn't by me manually creating all of
them that would have taken forever but
if I click on one of these you'll see a
few things first of all this is pink
we've got this like pink square here so
what is this this is the current way of
looking at the actual size of the box
Collider so you can see over here in the
properties we have a box Collider 2d
it's set to it's got an offset of zero
zero and a size and the size is very
specific size here but really all it is
is it's half the scale because this cube
is one meter squared or rather one meter
cubed but the physics I guess is one
meter squared and so what we because we
know that that's the case if I just set
a scale of four point four eight then
and box2d deals with half extents then
half of that is going to be exactly
right you can see if I change this I can
actually change the size of this
Collider so that's what's happening
there at the moment we're displaying the
latter as a pink square because I don't
think we can render rectangles in Hazel
at the moment so in other words they
have to be filled and that's why that's
why you're looking at this so this was
just obviously me not me being a little
bit lazy and not implementing drawing
rectangles because I was trying to work
on physics so there we have that yeah so
it's electing all of these what I've
done is I've manually just you know made
the collider the right size at the
moment if I was to like create an empty
entity over here and then add like well
we'll just add a out of box Collider to
it I guess you can see that the box
Collider is just gonna be initialized
with a size of one by one and then it's
really gonna take me actually trying to
resize it and do all of that stuff to
actually get it to be the right size
according to the mesh so there's no kind
of automatic sizing at the moment it
will just it'll just be one by one and
then you can resize it to what you want
so that's what I've done with this plane
here again this is a 3d plane in 3d
space but physics is in 2d so what we do
is we just well we pretend it's 2d
basically and we'll just make it take up
the whole space which is what it's doing
here again you can see the size is 25
that's half of the half of the X scale
and then for y as well it's half of the
Y scale now this is a static rigidbody
2d whereas these are all dynamic and
that of course means that they will move
around the physics system will kind of
move them and they'll respond to physics
whereas static means that the physics
system does not kind of control it it
just it's something that we can
essentially collide with so that's what
we have here okay cool what else
oh and obviously the player which is
this one here the player has the player
cube script module attached to it and a
horizontal and vertical force that we
can set up here it said that it's also a
dynamic rigidbody 2d with like a cloud
or everything set up so if we hit play
now you can say that this will simulate
our 2d physics which is really cool now
one of these is the player and if I if I
hold Q as you saw with the script I'll
actually see it so this one here if I
try and move this with the WASD Keys not
actually working at the moment so this
is what I mean I'm not sure why that
happened maybe because there's yeah I
don't think I think it worked because I
think it didn't work because there
wasn't our force coming out and there
were obviously entities on top
so you can see it kind of we can move it
with the WASD Keys we can crash it into
things and it works it works pretty
nicely now there is I think the material
is quite quite full of friction here
which is probably why sometimes picks up
these cubes but also even though these
cubes look tiny to us they're 1 by 1
meter so that's why the physics can look
a little bit clunky here oh okay it fell
asleep that's probably what happened
because now I can't actually
okay well listen let's do this as an
experiment I promise I have not tested
this I have no idea if it's if it's
gonna work but I'll actually change the
wake to true in all of this for all of
the WASD keys and sorry the da and space
key so if I rebuild this by just hitting
ctrl shift B and hit play again it
should actually just work because we had
the reload assembly on play checked so
this is the player so let's kind of make
it settle so that it like falls asleep
and then now if I wait a bit and I move
it there you go
so I think that that's working now so
that's pretty cool that's a nice way to
demo the physics for the script
reloading actually working even though
that I promise you that wasn't scripted
no pun intended
and I had no idea that would happen but
yeah there you go and you know if we
wanted to change it from red to like
green or blue or something like that if
I go back to my script again and I
decide to say that actually I want it to
be green controls you have to be to
build back here hit play and now it's
green so you can see that turnaround
time is so fast now which is really cool
and also hitting play does not take a
year like it does in unity I have no
idea what they're possibly doing to make
it take that long like seriously look at
this is I have the simplest of unity
scenes here there's one light there's a
camera and there's a one cube and if I
hit play look at that let's do it again
what is it doing but you can see I can
play and stop so quickly here which I
think it's really cool and obviously
like we're not doing anything too fancy
at the moment but we could be and
everything is kind of working is that
all I wanted to show I think it is
everything that I wanted to show
what I did for the other entities and
that's why you have that random color
thing this isn't really related to
physics but you know for this long thing
for this long kind of box here I can add
the script component that was called
example to random color I think yeah and
so now if I hit play it's gonna be a
random color every time I play now the
color doesn't get reset you'll know so
that's one little thing that doesn't
really happen correctly and the reason
it doesn't get reset is because at the
moment that script is permanently
modifying the actual mesh asset
so the mesh has a material and we're
actually setting the uniform of the
material to be that kind of random color
so because the script is kind of
permanently modifying an asset and
there's no copy of that asset happening
which is probably something that you
want to happen during runtime then it's
it kind of possessed slike this so the
entity itself is being completely redone
but the entity is still the entity still
has a reference to a particular asset
and that change is more or less
permanent anyway that's it if you have
any questions about anything that I've
done here please ask them in the comment
section below because at this point it's
it's not gonna be long I think before I
actually start making Morel his
tutorials on how to do things in hazel
as well as showing you guys how
everything works and the general
usability I guess of this engine I also
want to start doing some live streams
just for everyone not just for patrons
where I try and make games with this
because I would be really interested I I
would be really interested in seeing
your feedback seeing this kind of in
action as well as features and ideas
that you might have and I think it'll
just be fun and a good time anyway if
you guys enjoyed this video please don't
forget to hit the like button below and
again if you want to see something in
action or if you have any comments or if
you want to see how something works then
also let me know and I'll try and make
some videos talking about that thank you
all for watching I'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]